for the last five years new york's
laguardia airport has been undergoing an
8 billion upgrade and according to the
port authority of new york and new
jersey its transformation will be
complete next spring the old airport
which was probably one of the most hated
airports in the country will have been
transformed into one of the best but
rebuilding an entire airport while
keeping it functional for up to 50 000
passengers on busy days is no easy feat
so how did the port authority pull it
off and what can travelers expect going
forward
renovating laguardia airport involved
tearing down and rebuilding every single
passenger facility with the exception of
the landmark marine air terminal and
since it remained an active airport
renovations had to be done one area at a
time the construction pattern had to be
that you built a new
passenger facility
you put that into use and it was then
and only then that you could tear down
the old the pandemic brought challenges
such as having to enforce strict safety
protocols for workers on the
construction project but the drop in
passengers did make it easier to
construct new roadways you could
actually confine the traffic to
individual lanes so that construction on
the new terminals could accelerate
because you could use those for cranes
for other construction equipment the
port authority says the airport is
currently about halfway through
renovations and so far there have been
some positive reactions we've heard from
pilots we've heard from airline staff
i've actually
been
in the airport
when
passengers come out of a jet way having
just got off of a plane where they do a
complete double take and say did i get
on the wrong airplane terminal b is 90
finished and features art greenery four
airline lounges and 42 new shops and
restaurants the port authority says that
one key difference between the old and
new terminal b is that almost all of the
shops and restaurants are located after
security so travelers can shop and dine
while waiting for their flights there's
also a sky bridge that allows passengers
to walk over active taxiways as you
drive up to the airport on the
departures level you will see an
extraordinary vista of the manhattan
skyline there's one brand new concourse
which is quite striking that looks out
both on flushing bay and on city field
terminal c which is being built by delta
airlines is set to open next spring
all of the new passenger facilities have
also moved closer to the main highway
this way aircrafts have more space to
taxi and there could be fewer issues
getting to their gate now we're seeing
an airport emerge which is what the
region deserves what what travelers
deserve what employees of all of the
employers at the at the airport deserve